hall of famer he won the Super Bowl
twice NFL Network analyst you can follow
trill Davis on Twitter at Terrell
underscore Davis he joins us now TV how
are you good morning dad how you doing
okay here's a question we had earlier
the new Super Bowl odds are out and it's
the Saints number one on that list
followed by the Rams and then the Chiefs
if I gave you two teams and I took the
rest to win the Super Bowl which two
teams are you taking I'm definitely
going with Saints right now and I have
to go I think Kansas City a little
better than the ramps for me it's our
goal KC
what is it about Kansas City aside from
the offense they like do they have so
much offense that it can overshadow or
make up for what they may not have on
defense yeah I know we're saying that
we're saying that they can put so much
points and so much stress on your
defense but I'm at some point I want to
point out we all know that defense has
to make a stop here or there but before
this has been through in tremendous and
they're just using it they got some
pieces that I've seen that times make
some plays and some stops and that's
what you want you just want to defense
that they're not to be this sort of
shutdown defense but a ban but don't
break make some crucial plays and
crucial moments and when I look at the
landscape of other teams I just don't
see teams who can sort of match we won't
compete with them for 60 minutes and I
decided for like Kansas City I mean we
know their history though the history
suggests that when they want to get to
the playoffs that you know it's not
gonna be good for them but I don't know
there's something different about this
team that maybe they're surpass there
are their previous experiences and maybe
this is Patrick with Holmes you know the
magic of him may continue but I think
right now I'm certainly gonna Kansas
City and I'm going to Orleans what will
it take for a running back to be named
MVP again ah
that's a good question because it seems
like it's just that that that honor is
it's a quarterback award now you know
they the last practice when it was
Adrian Peterson but certainly if you up
there
around 2,000 yards if your team is doing
well if you have a quarterback that is
that is not one of the big names then I
think that gives you a good shot to be a
named MVP yeah I wonder I because I look
at Todd Gurley and you know you're just
not a running back anymore you know
Le'Veon Bell
it's like Marshall Faulk was so far
ahead of everybody at that position it
feels like Ricky Watters was there as
well Roger Craig like you had these guys
who were dual threats there it feels
like if you're playing the position now
you have to be that duals dual threat
and Gurley is that I just I think
Patrick mahomes and Drew Brees are
getting all the headlines there but and
here's another Lee might be the most
valuable player for the Rams but not be
the most valuable player in the NFL does
that does that make sense it makes it
yeah yeah it makes sense
I think he's for their team he's the MVP
you know he was off his Player of the
Year last year and I was kind of looking
back on my career and how it was kind of
stair step I think I was uh I was off as
a player of the year and then it kind of
gotten people looking at you took a city
or for MVP and make sure I end up
getting it and I thought at the end of
this beginning of the season Todd Gurley
was my league MVP and to me he is he's
been doing everything that came I asked
him to do you talked about it he could
catch the ball out of the backfield he
is that piece a if he's not there what
do the Rams look like offensively
I know Jared golfers look look pretty
good but girlies that engine he's an
engine that drives at office and without
him I just don't know if the Rams are
where they are today did lady on Bell
make the right decision coming from a
running back perspective I do that cause
I knew you asked a question you know
it's hard because so did this to I think
for me as two perspectives one I put
myself in his shoes and I say could I
have just held out and missed on all 14
million dollars and answer's no okay
not that I mean every week I'm saying
that checked
$800,000 check not being cashed but you
know when I'm playing I didn't make a
lot of money when I played so that's
that's just me from a whole different
standpoint I understand what he's doing
though because so the second point I get
it he has placed a value on his talent
and he made a decision that he's not
gonna play for anything less than what
he feels his market value is I respect
that because he's also doing it for
other players behind him he's making a
sense and we know when people make a
stance and they're doing things that
they feel is best for them and for the
game that people found upon that so I
respect that bleed I this they would
have been hard for me to do what he's
doing so yeah for him it's a he is doing
the right thing especially because of
the injury factories and I'm not gonna
be I'm not gonna say what happened to
Alex Smith yesterday is is it's a victim
that can happen a levy on bail but it's
a reminder that you really are one play
away from from being injured or really
having a career-ending injury so yeah
that standpoint he's like listen I'm not
gonna play until I get the money I
deserve and what I feel like my fair
market value is and and so you made this
decision and he's speaking with us so I
respect them for that I respect you for
that but for me back then I don't know
if I could have I don't know how to do
that he's thrilled Davis NFL Network and
yeah I don't I don't know if I could
have either but I understand what his
motivation is and trying to protect
himself for his next contract I also
wanted to ask you about Lamar Jackson we
know that he has this ability I don't
know if it's sustainable to be able to
run the ball 27 times but if you're John
Harbaugh both quarterbacks are healthy
and you may you may be coaching for your
job in Baltimore what would you do with
the quarterbacking position well yeah
Lamar is you watched him we see what his
development looks like he's he's
developing into a quarterback that is
learning the NFL game and in the
meantime they're saying be who you are
if I'm John Harbaugh I've gotta save my
job I'm playing the guy in this case
Lamar Jackson that I think can win games
for me
apparently yes
case because in training camp the world
was coming out that he wasn't ready and
you have rg3 on the bench and you've got
some you know people probably are
thinking of rg3 of old but I don't know
last time I saw orgies in the free city
looks pretty good to me so they
obviously feel that Lamar Jackson is a
better option for them and that he can
give them wins right now
and typically then artists that young
quarterback as he use his feet he's
gonna he's gonna be able to get you in a
lot of bad situation makes them play and
you sort of ride that and I think that's
what's happening right now feel like
they're saying hey he he can give us a
few wins right now and just sort of hold
this thing afloat until either Flacco
comes back or or maybe he can finish up
a fever like this I don't know but yeah
I think I'll ride with you I'll see what
he has and I think at the same time it
gives you a chance to wait like can Eli
Manning when when this job for next
season by how he plays the rest of this
season I don't think so
I know people were looking at Eli and
they look at his resumes
once you superpose and you know
obviously being a manís it's a decent
career for the last couple of years Eli
hasn't played do where you say we don't
need find another quarterback they need
to have somebody ready to replace Eli
and that to me that starts now
even if you finished off this year and
he looked great I think you still are
going to the next year saying we've got
to find a replacement for Eli because if
you don't we know we've seen stretches
in his career we haven't looked great at
all and then we started to hear the
questions about whether he's done or not
and if those questions and those
questions surface next year you want to
be prepared with a quarterback that you
can put in there and feel good about it
so I don't I don't think this year what
he does the remaining of this year will
impact whether if they find a new
quarterback and I think they have to
find they have to go find another
quarterback where all of them how he
finishes out TD good to check in with
you as always and you can follow Trel
Davis on Twitter at Terrell underscore
Davis the NFL Network analysts good to
talk to you thank you for your time
thank you have a good night buddy that's
uh TD for more dan Patrick
to the audience channel 239 on Direct TV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]